hi Kelly Clarkson thanks for including  us in your good neighbor challenge my  name is father Manny and I'm here at st.  Anne Catholic Church in Columbus Georgia  and yeah we came up with this idea about  a week ago I think it was and I saw  pictures from a church in Italy where a  priest did the same thing he wanted to  see his parishioners because he can't  anymore because of the quarantine and so  he has their faces in the pews as we  celebrate Mass and we look out we can  still see them we're able to stay  connected with our parishioners through  a livestream so they get to see us but  now this is our chance to get to see  them for all of you watching let's keep  this going  join the campaign let's be good  neighbors together  [Music]  you  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my channel please don't  make me keep going